[Musique]
étrangère
[Musique] [Musique] [
Musique]
pêche, vous pouvez louer des bateaux, vous pouvez naviguer,
vous pouvez louer des maisons ou des chalets sur le
lac, nous avons aussi la Reine Catawba, ils
ont deux bateaux là-bas, la Dame du
lac et la  Catawba Queen sur lequel vous
pouvez prendre un déjeuner et une croisière ou vous pouvez
faire un dîner-croisière,
vous aimez les idées normales
[Musique]
étrangère,
ils ont dit que c'était un grand puits
ressemblant à un dauphin qui venait en quelque sorte d'atteindre
l'eau et avait, vous savez, une piste  pendant
quelques minutes, puis je suis redescendu,
traîné sous l'eau par une créature dans ce
lac,
un long type de lézard avec
beaucoup de dents et quatre petites pattes, cela semble
être la description courante de lui.
J'ai entendu des gens en parler,
euh,
témoin  étrange
mais dans l'eau et peut-être éveillé
suite à quelque chose qui a été
partiellement vu partiellement invisible,
j'avais une tête d'alligator avec un
corps de serpent avec deux nageoires sur le côté
avec des griffes sortant de ces nageoires, c'est ce que
j'ai vu
[Musique]
étranger
le monstre du lac Norman et bien sûr
ajoute un monstre de lac ici qui est
réputé pour habiter ce lac qu'ils ont
construit, ils l'ont terminé en 1963
et bien sûr ils ont créé cet
immense lac, le plus grand lac de Caroline du Nord,
il fait plus de 35
000 acres de
Depuis que cela s'est produit, il y a eu beaucoup
d'histoires professionnelles, les gens
ont parlé de voir différentes
choses dans l'eau
[Musique]
après la construction du barrage, bien sûr, c'était
une zone de pêche fertile, il y avait beaucoup
de rochers et de bûches et ce genre de choses.  Ce qui est important
pour que les poissons vivent, dans
l'histoire principale que nous avons entendue, c'est qu'on n'allait
jamais nager au barrage parce qu'il
y avait les plus grosses Volkswagen de poisson-chat
et des filles que l'on pouvait identifier à un poisson aussi
gros qu'une Volkswagen,
ce qui serait assez intimidant.
]
grêles de plongeurs, ce serait en bas en train
d'inspecter le barrage qui reviendrait
et dirait que vous ne croirez pas ce que j'ai vu
et cela n'a fait qu'alimenter le euh dans l'
ensemble, n'allez pas nager là-bas parce qu'il y a quelque
chose là-bas
et bien sûr  les histoires du
monstre du lac Norman Normie, il y a eu
diverses observations de Normie et
certaines sont crédibles, d'autres peut-être pas, je ne l'
ai pas cité
personnellement bien que nous ayons un lac assez grand
et une eau assez profonde,
[Musique]
honnêtement, rien de cette taille, je  J'ai déjà
vu auparavant faire un tel sillage où cela
ferait bouger un voilier qui est
en fait plutôt un chien ouais, c'était
assez gros
[Musique]
Je ne pensais pas qu'il y avait quelque chose
d'aussi gros dans les lacs comme peut-être dans l'
océan mais c'est  était vraiment grand et je ne
savais pas ce que c'était
[Musique]
grandir près du rivage Je sais à quoi
ressemblent les baleines chez les requins, je les ai vus
Les dauphins évidemment ici en Caroline du Nord
dans la région des lacs, vous savez, vous voyez de gros
poissons et  des choses comme ça mais rien
de tel si j'étais le genre de gars
à prendre des photos et à envoyer
des SMS aux gens, alors j'ai définitivement vu
quelque chose qui sortait un peu de l'
existence ordinaire
[Musique]
étrangère [
Musique] [Musique]
[Musique  ]
la rivière Catawba est en quelque sorte imprégnée
d'histoire et de légendes, il y a une
tradition, une longue tradition d'
animaux en peluche, des créatures mystérieuses
habitant cette rivière bien avant qu'ils
ne creusent ce lac.
Je connaissais la rivière Catawba parce que
nous chantions et pêchions  la
rivière Catawba depuis près de Troutman jusqu'à l'endroit
où ils ont construit le barrage
comme Norma couvre maintenant plus de
530 miles de rivage, donc elle est énorme, elle est
plus grande que la mer de Galilée et il est
difficile d'imaginer qu'il puisse y avoir des
créatures cachées dans les profondeurs parce que
c'est assez profondément ici, là où
passait la rivière d'origine. L'
un des meilleurs exemples aurait
été celui des Indiens Catawba qui
racontaient l'histoire d'un
gars qui vivait dans un petit
village du côté est de la
rivière et qui traversait en canoë.  la rivière et
il chassait là-bas et il voit
cet énorme animal qu'il a vu donc
il ne savait pas ce que c'était, il était
là sur la rivière alors il se lève
et enquête et c'est un serpent géant
donc c'est un  Indien courageux, il pense bien, tu
sais, ce serait plutôt bien de montrer ça
si je te ramenais à la maison, tu sais et
donc il le prend et le
tire avec son arc et ses flèches, il
frappe et il n'a pas tué, il a juste rebondi
mais qu'est-ce qu'il  est-ce que cela a rendu cet animal
fou alors la créature a lâché ce qu'elle
attaquait et a tué l'Indien a tué
le brave alors euh il est mort là-bas, son
village, vous savez, a vu ce qui s'était passé
et tout ça et selon la légende,
parfois, il entraînait les gens dans  la
rivière, il y avait un Crossing Place et elle
les entraînait dans une piscine profonde
et les emmenait là-bas et les tuait
donc
j'ai entendu dire qu'il y avait des histoires mais je
n'ai jamais pensé qu'il s'agissait de
créatures étranges quand j'étais petite
c'est quelque chose de nouveau, vous savez, ce
monstre normand tardif, je pense que lorsque vous obtenez une euh
une grande étendue d'eau, des choses comme
celle-ci apparaîtront, il y a toutes sortes d'
histoires qui circulent à propos de monstres
et quelqu'un a nommé l'un d'eux
Normie d'après le lac Norman I.  je pense que c'est
incroyable et tu sais, c'est un peu amusant, tu
sais, je n'en ai jamais vu moi-même, j'étais
juste intéressé par la capture de poissons
étrangers,
il y a eu une sorte de lacune, tu connais
beaucoup de gens dans leurs connaissances, donc
bien sûr, tu as ces histoires
depuis les années 1800, puis au
20ème siècle,
cette dernière manifestation est apparue vers
l'an
2000.
J'ai lancé le site Web Lake Norman
monster.com après avoir passé quelques
années ici à pêcher sur le lac et à visiter
les locaux.  les magasins d'appâts parlent à d'autres
pêcheurs et entendent simplement des queues de poisson
qui se sont produites, vous le savez, de
toute l'histoire du lac
et cela s'est transformé en un petit passe-temps juste
pour que les gens viennent et publient anonymement des
observations et ont grandi à partir de là et ont
continué à grandir et ont continué à grandir  et
nous avons maintenant plus d'une décennie d'observations
à travers le lac Norman monster.com,
honnêtement, j'ai été surpris par le nombre
d'observations qui sont apparues sur le
site Web. Le journal local de l'époque a
récupéré le site Web assez rapidement et a
publié un article à ce sujet, puis
le  le revêtement a vraiment commencé à
arriver, vous savez, le premier mois, nous avons
eu 47 visiteurs, le deuxième mois, nous en avons
eu plus d'un millier et ça a juste grandi à
partir de là
demain dimanche matin, c'est bien, bien
assis juste sur la rive, c'est
[Musique]
et bien, j'étais fini  ici, c'était un samedi
soir et je marchais sur ce chemin et
nous avons vu une chaise dans le lac et j'ai dit à
Amelia, tu sais, allons-y et pourquoi
ne cours-tu pas chercher une chaise dans le
lac, elle était redoutée plus habillée  pour cela
et elle avait couru partout et alors qu'elle
courait sur le chemin pour arriver de ce
côté du lac, j'ai vu la chaise
rebondir de haut en bas et j'ai commencé à
regarder cette chaise sauter de haut en bas hors de
l'eau, la chaise était comme  au
milieu du lac et juste à côté de la
chaise, la tête s'est levée et a laissé un énorme
sillage et elle nageait très vite
ce que j'ai vu sortir du lac était une
longue tête comme un alligator
euh mais elle avait définitivement un corps long  et ce qui s'est
passé, c'est qu'il a quitté la chaise,
il s'est en fait déplacé de l'autre
côté de la crique là où
je me tenais et je me suis lavé et j'ai
commencé à nager jusqu'au voilier,
puis derrière le voilier, il a créé un tel
sillage que le voilier  se
déplaçait en fait de haut en bas et créait un sillage,
il attaquait évidemment quelque chose mais
nous avions lavé cette créature pendant environ 10
minutes, peut-être même 15 minutes et elle a
lavé la nage d'avant en arrière
de chaque côté de la crique
étrangère,
il y a beaucoup de bien  raisons pour lesquelles le
barrage est un endroit qui attire les poissons,
en particulier les gros poissons, c'est
là que sont capturés certains des plus gros poissons-chats
du lac, certains des
plus gros bars rayés, regardez là-bas,
de nombreuses observations de Normie ont
été observées au barrage,
il y a un  ce qu'ils appellent un trou chaud
près de la centrale électrique où ils remettent l'
eau dans le lac et qui maintiennent
cette zone au chaud toute l'année, donc pendant l'
hiver, il y a des
endroits où les gros poissons peuvent rester, se
nourrir et grandir,
c'est très très très profond donc à certaines
périodes  de l'année où les conditions
ne sont pas celles qu'ils aiment dans ces
zones moins profondes, les poissons descendent dans
ces eaux profondes, en particulier en
hiver et en été, c'est juste un
endroit pour eux pour passer du temps,
parfois peut-être même pour hiberner.  s'ils
ne se nourrissent pas, ils peuvent simplement se reposer
là-bas parce que c'est un peu plus
éloigné et si profond qu'ils
passent inaperçus,
vous savez, les poissons n'arrêtent vraiment pas de grandir
s'ils ont une bonne réserve de nourriture s'ils
ont un gros  assez de surface pour qu'il
puisse y avoir des poissons assez gros dans et
autour des trous chauds, le SE continue de
croître et de croître et de croître
[Musique]
génétique
eh bien, vous savez, à chaque fois que vous avez une
centrale nucléaire sur un lac ou une batterie d'
eau  vous allez avoir de l'eau plus chaude,
nous pouvons nager ici en février et
en mars parce que l'eau est tellement
réchauffée par les nouvelles de ces réacteurs nucléaires, donc
nous avons de gros poissons-chats ici, les poissons ont tendance
à devenir un peu plus gros mais encore une fois
à partir de  ce que j'ai vu quelque chose d'aussi gros était
assez incroyable, euh à voir
[Musique]
vous savez très bien que cela pourrait être un croisement,
je veux dire, ce
lac était artificiel, il a été rempli, vous
savez, à partir du barrage qu'ils ont construit en 1963.  ... donc
vous savez, il pourrait s'agir d'un croisement d'
une sorte de créature ou d'animal qu'ils
n'ont jamais vraiment
trouvé ou quoi que ce soit
[Musique]
la plus grande possibilité est le
croisement, il y a des poissons dans le lac
Norman qui sont hybrides, ce sont des poissons qui
ont été  mis dans le lac Norman pour aider à
contrôler des choses comme les mauvaises herbes envahissantes hydrilla
qui ne sont pas indigènes et sont
censées être stériles,
mais
vous savez qu'il y a cette excellente citation de
Jurassic Park, la vie trouve toujours un moyen, il
est donc possible que vous connaissiez certains de
ces poissons hybrides dans lesquels ils ont mis  le
lac n'est pas stérile et se sont
reproduits et hybridés avec d'autres
poissons qui sont dans le lac
[Musique]
vous savez, je me demandais s'il y
avait une vérité derrière cette histoire et oh,
c'est juste une de ces choses dont
les gens parlent mais ayant été  ici
depuis 40 ans, c'est quelque chose que tant d'
histoires, tant de coïncidences ne peuvent pas
être basées sur les chutes, elles doivent être basées
sur des faits
chez des personnes réputées de tous âges et de tous
horizons, il y a toujours quelqu'un
qui l'a vu ou a vu une partie de
lui  queue alors qu'il descend sous l'
eau, qu'est-ce que ça pourrait
être, tu sais, c'est la prépondérance des
preuves qui lui donne du crédit dans mon
esprit même si je ne l'ai jamais vu,
j'avais peur parce que je nage dans cette
eau tout le temps et je  J'ai trop
peur pour y aller maintenant parce que je ne
sais pas ce que c'est. Non, je suis une sorte de
sceptique. Je pensais que c'était peut-être juste un
type de poisson différent ou quelque chose que
nous n'avions jamais vu auparavant dans ces eaux,
mais  J'ai moi-même un bateau et je n'ai jamais
rien vu de tel. C'était comme une tête
d'alligator avec une nageoire sortie
avec des griffes au bout. Ce
n'est pas seulement un poisson moyen qui pourrait
secouer un voilier entier qui est en fait
amarré
mes amis nagent dans cette eau tout le
temps et je leur ai demandé s'ils avaient vu
quelque chose comme ça et ils ont dit non,
ils ne m'ont pas cru au début quand je
l'ai dit parce qu'ils étaient comme si rien n'était
si grand dans le lac mais je  c'était comme si je
l'avais vu et nous en avons des photos.
[Musique]
nous avons demandé à des utilisateurs d'envoyer des photos de
choses qu'ils voient dans le lac et c'est
difficile de le répéter, c'est difficile de juger
des distances, vous savez que vous voyez une tête ou
un  corps avec un poids derrière lui, cela pourrait
être un petit animal qui nage, cela pourrait être,
vous savez, un cerf traversant le lac, cela
pourrait être quelque chose qui sort de l'eau
par le bas pour manger, donc vous savez, il y a
quelques photos,
quelques histoires qui m'ont fait me demander si
c'était vrai ou non, l'un d'entre eux a
en fait été soumis par une enseignante
qui avait emmené sa classe en croisière
sur l'un des bateaux de croisière locaux
et elle a soutenu que
toute la classe de 25 à 30 enfants a vu
quelque chose briser l'eau et partir  en
arrière, donc vous savez, un groupe de masse
s'est rangé là-bas et cela m'a fait penser qu'il y avait
peut-être quelque chose d'important là-bas.
L'une des choses qui plaideraient en faveur de la
possibilité d'être un
gros animal ici est le fait que
le  l'histoire n'est pas isolée du lac Norman
mais vous la trouvez dans ce même
système fluvial, vous la voyez là-haut et le lac
James a son histoire de monstre, vous
voyez aussi celle le long du Santee
dans le lac Murray. J'ai même croisé un
compte  d'un monstre marin aperçu
à l'embouchure de la rivière Santee
entre Georgetown et Charleston, donc s'il
y a
une sorte de grande créature, il y a une
rivière avec elle comme candidate dans ce
coin du bois pour devoir abriter
une sorte de grand  créature aquatique
qui existe depuis des millénaires, même
avant l'arrivée des Amérindiens, ce
serait l'antiquité américaine qui
dirait au système
[Musique]
étrangère
qu'il n'y avait pas grand-chose, il n'y en avait pas dans de nombreux
sillages ou quoi que ce soit
nous avons remarqué que l'eau a
commencé à monter tout d'un coup et
c'est justement le
réveil qui est apparu
[Musique]
ce qui est étrange à propos de ce que nous avons vu, c'est
que
de chaque côté, le sillage mesurait entre 10 et 15
pieds de long et il  était assez haut, il mesurait
peut-être environ un pied de haut, il
montait un peu assez pour
que l'on puisse voir le haut de sa peau
et il avait à peu près la couleur d'un lac
comme
euh, comme une couleur brun verdâtre
qu'il faisait.  tout en bas vers cette
crique ici même sur l'île Ranger après l'avoir
perdu de vue, nous avons entendu des oies là-bas
qui traînaient dans la crique,
elles ont juste décollé, vous savez, elles
faisaient beaucoup de bruit et elles ont juste
décollé donc c'était gentil  de bizarre aussi
[Musique]
Je passe environ 200 jours par an sur l'
eau
Je ne peux tirer des conclusions que sur la base de
mes propres expériences Je passe beaucoup de temps
sur l'eau
Il y a beaucoup de choses que l'on peut voir
sur le lac Norman qui  nous considérerions cela comme
inhabituel,
mais si vous les regardez attentivement, la plupart
d'entre eux sont explicables.
[Musique]
J'ai vu des canoës à l'envers flottant dans
l'eau, maintenant un canoë sous un certain
angle et dans un certain temps peut
ressembler à quelque chose qu'il n'est pas.  Nous avons
beaucoup de quais sur le lac et beaucoup de
choses soufflent dans l'eau des
quais des gens. J'ai ramassé un wakeboard de 10 pieds l'
année dernière au milieu du
lac
jusqu'au froid et sur le lac et si  il y a
des grottes sur le lac oui il y a
tout d'abord il y a des milliers
de criques sur ce lac
euh à l'extrémité inférieure du lac
où j'habite le lac est probablement
développé à 95 à mesure que l'on avance vers le nord sur
la rivière il y en a moins sur le lac
il y a  moins de développement et il y a
quelques petites criques là-dedans qui sont
envahies par les arbres et euh et des choses
qui ressembleraient à des tunnels dans les
arbres où l'on pourrait les définir comme une
grotte où quelque chose pourrait se cacher, bien sûr, il y en a
sur tous
les lacs,
merci
J'ai appris au cours de mes 77 années à ne jamais
dire jamais
et à ne jamais dire impossible en ce qui concerne la
présence d'un être vivant dans le lac
Norman qui est surdimensionné, disons-le
ainsi,
car pour ce que j'ai vu, je ne pourrais jamais
vraiment comprendre ce que  ça pourrait
être, vous savez, compte tenu de l'histoire des poissons et de
leurs personnalités et vous savez, quand
ils arrivent au sommet et prennent l'air et
juste ouais, ce n'était pas le cas, ce n'était pas comme
un comportement que vous savez que vous pourriez
penser d'un poisson  même comme un
poisson-chat géant, ce sont des Bottom Feeders, ils restent
vers le fond, vous savez, et s'il
arrivait et traînait comme je ne le fais pas, je
ne vois tout simplement pas comment il resterait éveillé
comme ça, c'était tellement bizarre
mais  J'aimerais savoir,
euh, ce qu'il y a dans ce lac que les gens continuent
de signaler et qu'ils voient, vous
savez, cela pourrait être une nouvelle espèce qui
n'a jamais été découverte,
vous savez, tout autour du lac euh Norman et
juste en Caroline du Nord, juste la
rivière Catawba là-bas.  il y a tellement d'observations et
de lacs que vous savez, c'est vraiment étrange, il y a
quelque chose là-dedans
[Musique]
légendaire
[Musique] [Musique
]
[Musique]
eh bien, ce que nous allons faire aujourd'hui, c'est que
nous allons chercher Normie le lac
normand  monstre,
c'est une quête que nous menons depuis 10
ou 15 ans maintenant et euh, certains jours, nous en voyons
des indications, beaucoup de jours, nous
ne le voyons pas, mais nous avons du matériel électronique
sur le bateau, nous utiliserons notre  les yeux, nous utiliserons
nos oreilles
[Applaudissements]
ce que nous avons ici, c'est que nous avons des
appareils électroniques assez sophistiqués, euh,
nous avons un GPS
là où nous avons en fait une carte topographique
ici où nous pouvons voir le fond
Contours,
nous en avons deux,
nous avons deux appareils d'imagerie, celui-ci
montre de chaque côté du bateau, celui-
ci montre en fait que vous pouvez voir que
nous passons sur un petit tas de pinceaux ou
quelque chose juste là-bas, maintenant
il montrera des objets.  sous le bateau,
votre spectacle montrera les pouvoirs de pinceau du
poisson de spectacle, il montrera
tout ce qui passe juste en dessous,
maintenant, beaucoup de gens se trompent sur ce que
nous regardons là-bas et je pense
que c'est le monstre lui-même, en fait,
c'est le  banc de poissons-appâts tous
regroupés et c'est juste un banc de
poissons nageant ensemble, ils nagent
ensemble pour se protéger des plus gros
poissons,
voici notre bateau qui arrive le long de
ce tombant juste ici et ce que nous
allons faire maintenant, c'est nous  Je vais retourner
dans l'anse arrière ici
étrangère
[Musique] [
Musique]
tu remarqueras que nous sommes à 42 pieds d'eau
en ce moment, le lac est la raison pour laquelle le lac est
parfait pour une sorte de monstre, c'est qu'il
est aussi profond  comme 130 pieds, il fait 34 miles de
long, il fait sept miles de large, il y a
plein d'endroits pour euh un gros animal où se
cacher
[Musique]
étranger
alors que vous revenez dans certaines de ces
criques arrière comme celle-ci, vous voyez, c'est très calme, vous
ne voyez pas beaucoup de  les gens autour et
ces créatures peuvent glisser,
elles peuvent soit aller sous l'eau, soit
venir juste sous la surface
et elles glisseront dans et hors de ces
endroits et et elles ne seront jamais vues
parce que personne ne s'en soucie vraiment et  personne ne
les cherche
[Applaudissements]
un
lac étranger [Musique] a à peu près la même histoire où les
plongeurs sont là-bas en train de travailler et de faire
tout ce que les plongeurs font avec le barrage et tout
d'un coup le soleil est bloqué et les yeux se
lèvent et il y a quelque chose de gigantesque
nageant au-dessus d'eux et ils ont peur
et ils sortent de l'eau
et dans le cas du lac Norman, quand ils ont
fait part de leur décision à leur
patron, on s'est moqué d'eux
et euh,
ils n'ont juste pas dit qu'ils arrêteraient
mais ils  ils ne sont jamais revenus travailler et
ils ont juste refusé de
retourner dans le lac Norman parce qu'ils savent qu'ils ont
vu ce que nous cherchons
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements] [
Musique]
les étrangers
[Musique]
les spécialistes du sonar sont sous l'eau
détection d'image et j'ai des sonars sur
mes deux bateaux et ils sont toujours allumés depuis
le moment où je quitte le quai jusqu'à mon
retour et chaque fois que je vois une image
inhabituelle sur mon sonar, je prends une
photo de cette image avec  mon
appareil photo numérique l'a mis directement dans mon ordinateur et
j'ai des milliers et des milliers de
photographies d'images sous-marines et je
les utilise dans mes livres et je les utilise dans
mes conférences pour montrer aux gens ce qui se
passe sous l'eau,
voici une photo que j'ai prise de
quelque chose qui semble mesurer environ 15 pieds
de haut,
on pourrait même imaginer avoir une queue
dessus si vous regardez vers le bas sur le côté droit
c'est une photographie très courante c'est
un banc d'environ 2 000 perches que j'ai
vu sur mon sonar  J'ai vu
des images anormalement grandes sous l'eau, mais j'ai pu
les expliquer toutes, car en tant que très grands
bancs de poissons,
nous avons le nez retroussé dans ce lac,
c'est un poisson d'apparence très inhabituelle et
j'ai personnellement vu un gar de six pieds de long,
euh dans  l'eau et euh un garde pour
quelqu'un qui n'est pas habitué à voir des lépisostés, c'est
un poisson très étrange,
les gens ont peur d'eux mais ils
ne font vraiment aucun dommage, ils se
nourrissent vraiment de surface, ils gardent l'eau
propre et ils sont en fait un très bon
poisson à avoir dans le lac
si ce n'est pas un monstre dans le lac Norman, je
supposerais probablement que c'est un
gros poisson, cela pourrait être un gar, cela pourrait être
quelque chose, vous savez, nous
avons eu un alligator capturé dans le lac
qui était un animal de compagnie  qui a été relâché, donc
ils ne sont généralement pas originaires de cette région,
donc vous savez, cela aurait pu être quelque chose
comme ça
et puis vous savez que les gens sortent, il est
difficile de juger des distances sur le lac,
surtout si c'est tard dans la
journée ou tôt.  le matin et vous voyez
quelque chose, cela pourrait être très petit
près de vous ou cela pourrait être très grand et
très loin, vous savez, si vous n'êtes pas familier
avec la navigation sur le lac,
[Musique] fait
partie du problème que nous avons avec
ces observations rapportées et  les photographies,
c'est que nous n'entendons jamais les
conditions dans lesquelles nous sommes environnants à l'
époque, était-ce le printemps, était-ce l'hiver, était-il
venteux, n'était-il pas venteux, par exemple,
au bout de notre crique, ici, il y a
un très long banc de sable et il est très peu
profond  et au printemps, les grosses
carpes et ces carbus mesurent trois à quatre pieds de
long, ils sortent sur ce banc de sable
pour frayer
et ils frayent dans des eaux peu profondes près de la
surface et ils créent beaucoup de vagues.
Je les ai vus, j'ai été  voilà, j'ai
pêché dans ces zones quand ils frayaient
et ils créeront en fait si vous en
avez suffisamment pour frayer de la même manière,
ils créeront une petite vague d'
environ six à huit pouces de haut
[Musique  ]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] étrangère
en ce qui concerne la centrale nucléaire et vous
connaissez la possibilité de
radiation nucléaire, bien sûr, c'est toujours une
question que les gens se posent,
euh, à cause de ma formation technique et de
ma compréhension de la technologie de
cette centrale nucléaire particulière, je dirais  Je
doute beaucoup qu'il y ait
à nouveau une possibilité d'exposition aux radiations.
Je ne pourrai jamais dire que c'est impossible
parce que
vous savez, nous ne savons pas toujours ce qui
se passe à l'intérieur de cette usine.
La seule chose que je verrais qui
constituerait une menace parce qu'ils en pompent tellement
des gallons de ce lac à travers
le liquide de refroidissement du réacteur, vous savez, tous les
systèmes le refroidissent,
euh,
ils aspirent tellement d'eau, vous savez, environ
une fois et un tiers de ce qu'est le lac, c'est ce qu'on m'a
dit, mais
vous savez si quelque chose avait été
compromis.  et une sorte de matériel
a atteint le lac, ce qui est assez rare, je
pense, car il y a tellement de
normes de sécurité qu'ils doivent respecter,
mais je pense que ce que cela ferait vraiment,
c'est peut-être comme, euh,
juste un peu comme modifier génétiquement
leurs gènes, peut-être juste en quelque sorte  ou le rendre encore
plus malade, je ne pense pas qu'il pourrait développer
une énorme créature comme les gens le pensent,
et vous savez, parce que, comme si vous
regardiez ce que les radiations peuvent faire à vos
gènes et à vos cellules, cela ne fonctionne pas vraiment de
cette façon, c'est plus  juste rapide pour
te tuer et juste te donner
des difformités Je ne pense pas vraiment qu'il y ait
un lien entre la centrale nucléaire et
quoi que ce soit, surtout étant donné que
d'autres lacs par ici, tu sais qu'ils
voient des choses similaires, tu sais,
alors je  Je pense qu'il y a peut-être une
espèce, vous savez, nous avons 95 de nos
eaux qui sont tout simplement inexplorées, vous savez, alors
peut-être que
nous ne pouvons pas vraiment dire ce que c'est
jusqu'à ce que quelqu'un puisse rapporter des preuves
comme des données scientifiques vérifiables,
cela signifie, euh, pas de
preuve photographique mais  mais la créature elle-même
jusqu'à ce que quelqu'un puisse le faire, elle
restera juste une très bonne partie de notre
folklore qui est une partie précieuse de notre
ordonnance populaire, une partie de nos traditions
et de notre héritage et donc c'est juste une partie
la plus récente et  une longue série d'
histoires qui tentent en quelque sorte d'expliquer peut-être ce qu'ils
ne comprennent pas, ce qui est
ici, peut-être qu'ils voient là-bas, ils voient
des animaux, c'est juste la façon dont ils viennent
vers nous, viennent s'occuper de ce qui
vit là-bas
[Musique  ] des
histoires étrangères [Musique] [Musique] souvent, ils reviennent
et disent que j'ai attrapé un poisson et qu'il était si
gros, tu sais, à chaque fois que tu le racontes, il
devient de plus en plus gros donc tu sais, qui sait,
peut-être que quelqu'un a vu un  un gros Gator ou
quelque chose ici une fois et puis euh la
prochaine chose que vous savez, ils peuvent le dire
et c'est le monstre du Loch Ness qui nage
ici, on ne sait jamais mais euh
s'il y a quelque chose ici,
ce serait un candidat de choix pour un
de grandes créatures, bien sûr, il y a
beaucoup d'habitat ici, un grand lac
quand j'étais quand j'étais plus jeune, j'ai toujours
eu l'esprit ouvert sur les
possibilités des créatures paranormales
et des choses comme ça, mais euh,
comme je l'ai dit, je suis toujours un  enfant dans l'âme
et j'aimerais croire qu'ils
voient quelque chose là-bas, vous savez,
suffisamment de gens ont soumis des observations
et ont dit qu'ils avaient vu quelque chose, vous
savez, de toute évidence, il y a quelque chose là-bas,
ce que c'est, je ne sais pas, je ne pense pas
c'est une créature ressemblant à un dinosaure qui a
été mutée mais je pense qu'ils
voient quelque chose de grand et
d'inexpliqué et
L'Inexpliqué m'a déjà toujours
fasciné parce que je veux connaître la
réponse tu sais je veux je veux savoir
quelle est la réponse  c'est que je veux expliquer
cela et expliquer pour que les gens puissent y aller, oh c'est ce que c'est,
on ne sait jamais, euh, nous pourrions
rire d'eux, mais dans cent ans,
certains scientifiques, anthropologues,
pourraient s'asseoir là et dire que
c'est intéressant de voir comment ces
gens  développer cette histoire et comment
ils ont développé leur propre folklore pour
expliquer quelque chose dont ils ne savaient
rien
si vous revenez en arrière et regardez
une partie de l'histoire des débuts
de cette région ici dans
les années 1800, vous  Je verrai que
les histoires d'une grande créature
vivant dans la rivière étaient encore répandues
même à cette époque et même si
vous ne le savez pas vraiment, vous n'avez pas vraiment
trouvé de récit où ils disent oh vous
savez, tel ou tel vous a attrapé  Vous connaissez un
gros serpent ici ou là ou quoi que ce soit,
c'était tellement connu que
beaucoup de commerçants l'utilisaient dans
leur publicité et donc même à l'époque,
vous savez qu'ils connaissaient la valeur d'
avoir une sorte de créature inhabituelle pour ainsi
dire et  et d'un
point de vue touristique, salut les garçons et les filles, si l'un d'entre
vous a déjà entendu parler de Normie
Normie est un monstre de lac qui vit
ici même à Lake Norman, ma femme est
enseignante de troisième année dans une école privée locale,
elle a toujours voulu écrire un
livre pour enfants  et quand nous avons commencé à
faire les croisières touristiques sur les monstres du lac Norman,
nous avions besoin de quelque chose
pour divertir les enfants autre que de
simplement leur raconter des histoires et
elle a dit que j'avais toujours voulu écrire un
livre, c'est ma chance il y a quelques années, mon
mari et moi étions  parler et j'ai eu
l'idée d'écrire sur un livre
sur quatre enfants, un monstre normalement normal,
parce que nous avons pensé que ce serait
amusant de donner un visage amical au
monstre dont nous avons entendu parler,
alors j'ai passé quelques mois à écrire  vous
savez, demander de l'aide à
mes amis et qu'est-ce qu'ils entendent et que
remarquent-ils sur le lac et euh, j'ai inventé
une histoire sur la recherche normale d'
amis à laquelle je pense que beaucoup d'enfants peuvent
s'identifier
[Musique] et
bien, c'est généralement  nous les faisons pendant l'
été et c'est une croisière matinale amusante pour que
les enfants sortent avec leurs parents et qu'ils
entendent une histoire et qu'ils puissent
regarder le lac et c'est vraiment génial
car au fur et à mesure que nous avançons, nous
pouvons pointer du doigt  soulignez les choses dont nous avons
parlé dans le livre, comme
le balbuzard pêcheur sur le marqueur d'exposition et
soulignez certaines espèces de la faune locale. Lorsque
Normie a refait surface, il tenait un peu de
boue du fond du lac, est-ce que cela aiderait
Normy a demandé au balbuzard pêcheur de baisser les yeux.  Chez
Normie, face cachée dans l'eau, la
panique était plutôt sympa parce que les
enfants sont juste, ils sont vraiment dedans et ils
connaissent Normie,
ils en savent beaucoup plus sur Normie que
la plupart des gens ne le savent,
m'ignorent ouais une fois quand nous étions  en conduisant
jusqu'à l'école à
quoi ressemblait-il
euh c'était juste comme cette grosse bosse dans l'
eau je pense que c'était
ou quelque chose aurait pu être son
bâton dans celui-là de quelle couleur était-il
si vert verdâtre jaunâtre as-tu vu
des yeux non
non je pense  c'était le dos tu le
renvoies ouais maintenant qui d'autre m'a vu Normie
et ils sortent ici et et si tu
as 50 enfants sur le bateau, environ la moitié d'entre
eux le verront ou verront quelque chose qu'ils
pensent être ça et l'autre moitié probablement
peu importe
mais ce qu'ils feront quand vous leur demanderez
qu'avez-vous dit certaines personnes voient un gros
objet long certaines voient un gros objet rond
voient quelque chose avec de grands yeux une grande vieille nageoire
dorsale qui sort parfois c'est rouge
parfois c'est vert certains  Certains d'entre eux ont
des jumelles, certains d'entre eux ont les lunettes de soleil de leur mère
ou de leur papa, ils ont ces
longs chapeaux, des jumelles et et ils
s'amusent beaucoup,
merci, c'est parti,
un deux trois
[Musique]
là-bas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
étranger
Je pense que c'est un dragon qui sait nager
[Musique]
il a un gentil monstre
pour les enfants, une armée a un attrait unique
parce qu'il semble être un poisson amical
et ce genre de chose et quand nous  avons
notre festival au printemps, il s'appelle
le Ray City Festival, il y a toujours un
concours d'art et de coloriage juste pour voir qui
peut dessiner la ressemblance la plus proche avec une armée
et c'est donc une de ces choses qui
stimulent leur créativité, leur
talent artistique, ce genre de chose et
c'est  vraiment ce qui suscite l'intérêt et nous
avons des gens de partout au pays
qui veulent venir dans cette région
pour le festival et donc chercher
des ressemblances avec Normie est vraiment une de
ces attractions qui amènent les gens à
Mooresville
[Musique]
quand je pense  J'étais enfant, je donne un
exemple de la façon dont cela a changé quand j'étais
enfant si je voyais une automobile avec l'
étiquette d'immatriculation de Caroline du Sud
qui était un étranger et maintenant nous voyons
des gens du monde entier venir
ici
fin Norman  c'est
comme je dis un grand creux pour le tourisme, c'est
énorme
et surtout quand nous faisons ces voyages d'été
avec les enfants, nous en avons eu
jusqu'à cent et plus sur
les bateaux si vous comptez les parents et
tout et je veux dire  ils
s'amusent tout simplement et nous ne voudrions
pas que tant de gens
viennent pour autre chose que quelque chose d'excitant
comme ça et c'est juste ça, ça excite
l'imagination de ces petits gars et
ils nous font en quelque sorte continuer et  rajeunissez-nous aussi
ici,
c'est juste là
[Applaudissements]
et ce n'est pas normal
d'avoir Ray de jeunes enfants ici oh
oui, le monstre est bien réel et nous
avons fait de nombreux voyages à la recherche du
monstre, nous ne l'avons jamais vu mais nous savons
qu'il est là
[  Musique]
étrangère
[Musique]
nous essayons de faire de la pêche une activité de plein air
qui rassemble la famille
donc de ce point de vue, je pense que
c'est normalement très positif parce que
si une famille va monter dans un bateau ou
louer le bateau et partir  sur un lac avec
leurs enfants pour la journée et leur but
est de chercher une armée, c'est une bonne
chose, je pense que c'est bien de retirer les enfants
des ordinateurs, cela les fait sortir des
iPad, cela les fait sortir de l'iPhone et cela
les met  en plein air
Le mystère du monstre est un tirage au sort et
le problème est que nous avons de jeunes
enfants qui sortent tôt le
matin pour essayer de le capturer à First
Sunlight. Ils organisent des concours, des concours d'art
pour essayer de dessiner la légèreté du
monstre.
et donc je pense que cela ne fait qu'ajouter à
l'histoire et à l'amélioration de notre
lac et donc juste l'idée qu'il y a
quelque chose à découvrir
que peut-être personne n'a que personne d'autre n'a
jamais vu, je pense que tout le monde veut cette
opportunité
[Musique]
étrangère
sur les observations de monstres bien faite,
cela a souvent changé la façon dont
les gens veulent juste
sortir ici et faire du tourisme, l'une des
premières questions qu'ils posent est quelle est l'
histoire du monstre du lac Norman, qu'est-ce que c'est
la tempête ils ne connaissent même pas
son nom ils ne savent pas nous l'appelons
Normy et donc nous sortons ici et cela
devient une partie de notre partie de notre tournée
nous regarderons les belles maisons nous allons
nous allons  J'observe beaucoup d'oiseaux sauvages
pendant notre tournée
et vous savez, tout le monde
cherche ce monstre aussi, il
veut juste l'apercevoir [
Musique]
merci [
très bien
[Musique]